so with the flash confirming that
gorilla grodd is going to be a villain
in the TV show they're going to be a
good idea to make a video explaining the
origins of gorilla grodd but because we
don't know if the flash is going to use
the pre new 52 origin the new 52 origin
or even an origin of their own creation
what we're going to be doing here is
we're to be covering both the pre new 52
and the new 52 origins of gorilla grodd
so the pre new 52 origin is given to us
and secret origins volume 2 issue number
40 and what we find here is that
somewhere in Africa and alien ship crash
lands and as us being investigated by
several gorillas they're exposed to some
kind of technological device that seems
to have some kind of an effect on them
from here we switch to a couple of
explorers who stumble across the hidden
gorilla city which seems to be a highly
advanced place and once the presence is
discovered by the various gorillas
they're taken to the head of gorilla
City which is revealed to have been the
alien that had previously inhabited the
crashed spacecraft now what the alien
tells us here is that 11 years of past
since his initial introduction to the
gorillas and that during this time
they've gained telepathy telekinesis and
enhanced intelligence through their
exposure to the technological advice but
what alien also says is that while he's
worshipped by the gorillas as a king one
of the gorillas seeks to overthrow and
usurp his role and that as a result the
coming of the Explorers coincides with
the aliens plans to expose the world of
gorilla City to the world's existence
and so what we find here is that the
alien renders both explorers invisible
allowing them the ability to help the
alien escape both gorilla grodd as well
as make the world aware of gorilla
city's existence what happens though is
that while both of these men are trying
to escape with this alien that gorilla
grodd takes control of one of the
Explorers Minds forcing him to make
statements that depict fear and hatred
for the gorillas as well as killing off
the alien and so as a result the other
Explorer and the alien escape and
gorilla grodd assumes the role of king
of gorilla City declaring that all
humans are dangerous and that gorilla
City will remain hidden forever now from
here we switch to the new 52 origin and
with this origin what we find is that DC
switched things around quite a bit what
we learn is that barry allen has arrived
in gorilla City due to the flashpoint
event that rather than Gorilla Grodd and
the other gorillas developing enhanced
intelligence telepathy and telekinesis
due to alien technology that these
gorillas already seem to have enhanced
intelligence as well as an organized
lady what we also learn here is that
gorilla grodd is undertaking a rite of
passage in that he has to fight his
father to prove his worth of leading
gorilla City
now Grodd is successful in defeating his
father but the group also becomes aware
of Barry Allen's presence and so as a
result Barry Allen is taken prisoner by
the gorillas until Grodd can decide the
next course of action now during all of
this Barry Allen is informed by the
elders of the gorilla City that long ago
I guess that several generations ago
guru liza made contact with something
called the light now we're not
explicitly told what the light is but I
would go as far as to say this is most
likely a throwback to the original
secret away
I guess the original secret origin that
was given to us for Gorilla Grodd but
what we learned here is that this light
had originally jump-started the
evolution of these gorillas that had
given them clairvoyance as well as
enhanced intelligence telepathy and
maybe telekinesis we're not really sure
about the last two but what we know is
that contact with I guess with these
enhancements over the generations had
begun to go away leaving these gorillas
with nothing more than their enhanced
intelligence and so what the elders say
is that according to the old prophesies
that Barry Allen's coming was foretold
by the previous elders and that he would
help to lead their society out of his
old ways into a new destiny that would
they would be able to carve for
themselves but during this conflict
where we find as a gorilla grodd begins
to not only attack Barry Allen but also
begins to terror it here at the cave
around them and so as a result the cave
ends up collapsing in and it's presumed
that Gorilla Grodd is actually killed in
the process of course we know that
Gorilla Grodd will go on to survive in
the new 52 and so as a result the
gorillas are pretty much left without
their king but what they're informed by
Barry Allen of is that they have the
choice now to pursue their own destiny
they have the choice now to decide what
it is they want to do and to move
forward with that being said we're gonna
go ahead and bring this video to an end
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly